[Music]
welcome to every damn day today is South
Park preview we got it right here for ya
and I'm so scared
where's mom your mom's been out trying
to find you a lawyer and a therapist
we've been doing all we can dad that
thing we saw take Ned
it was manbearpig it was real what are
you talking about it was just a bear no
dad it why do you keep looking at the TV
what why I don't know what
you've been playing Red Dead Redemption
a little bit I mean when I'm not doing
all the stuff for you okay so the thing
that I like about this is that Randy
like South Park has been on long enough
to where like at first they very much
seems identify with the kids and like
that kind of world but now they're like
they seem to do all say everything they
want to say through Randy and that
includes like not actually parenting
which I love but he is wasting time when
there's like a climate change crisis or
a manbearpig crisis there's so many
crazy there's there's so many layers
what do you guys do to waste time I'll
watch an entire season of a show yeah
yeah do you do the thing where when
you're watching TV I also have to like
be like on my phone and like I just have
to do now watching TV now oh you watch
TV yeah watch and I just nail myself to
the cab like 1984 kind of like is that
the right reference when you're not in
the episode Nate it's I have the I have
the cards today I know who is Randy
I don't feel the rain the Hat we well as
ney likes to teach Randy also likes to
teach lessons and I have another clip
queued up right here alright everyone
eat up ah Jesus Christ sliced hot dogs
and tomato slices you said we had to be
careful with our money I've got nothing
for a food budget mom dead how come
there's suddenly no money I'll tell you
what happened son see there's a bunch of
idiots out there who weren't happy with
what they had they wanted a bigger house
and materialistic things that they
didn't even need people with no money
who got loans to buy frivolous things
they had no business buying these
assholes just blindly started buying any
stupid thing that looked appealing
because they thought money was endless
being less money coming in and the
idiots couldn't see that by doing all
this frivolous spending they were
mocking the economy and they made the
economy very angry we're all feeling the
economy's vengeance because of
materialistic heathens who did stupid
things with their money
do you understand son yeah I think I get
it we realized a few things one I'm
Randy and two Nate was actually
defending my original point of saying
that 1984 was the reference after all
and then I just screamed at okay so
Margaritaville mix like a bad stupid
thing to buy isn't it what's the dumbest
thing that you know I thought you meant
matches speaking of I bought a candle
that when you light it it sounds like a
crackling fire giving an example
something dumb yeah I've bought a few
trench coats every time I buy them wake
up this is gonna look
and I tried it on I'm like okay listen
you gonna do whatever there any time you
get naked in the other one weird are you
usually are usually on your friends
shoulders to get into the movies oh boy
that was pretty fun with Nate when you
host that's good Nate does I don't know
what that looks like I realize I'm looks
like I'm trying to start a fight and we
actually have a clip which will
transition nicely into this oh what a
bad transition that was
[Music]
that's enough the next person that
fights is getting his team disqualified
he's done for anyway
[Music]
come on get up yeah you have to fight
all right come on let's play ball
[Music]
get up get up
I didn't hear no Bell
[Music]
that's it that's it South Park is
disqualified it's a rocky reference man
I didn't hear any Bell just like a tale
of liquid courage fighting another dad I
mean if anybody haven't seen Rocky five
you don't need to watch it
you basically seen the whole thing rocky
v was one of the worst Rocky's ever
water worse rock it's it's one of the
worst what are the one with it is the
worst one but it's not that's one with
Tommy Gunn any titty and he's training
them and he's it's not it's not that bad
every one one attacked like rocky for is
so great before is great it's it's two
montages and like three but well maybe
is like three scenes and two training
months yeah then we should favor rocky
rocky two three one two scandal smell
then four then we have the right to say
whatever the Rockies are if orders in
the racket as a Philadelphian they rate
the rock you have to rock break it going
give a lifetime to break the we're on
the show right now I don't know think
about the clip of South Park rocky 4 is
the best rocky every day Oh clubber Lang
is the best bad guy when we got another
clip for you right cleverly everyone
below this line will have to be
evacuated to the south everyone above
this line is already dead
people like us in the middle states have
to ride it out the balmy southwestern
states might have a chance but New York
will have tidal waves that envelop all
of the Northeast
what Frank
Oh goddamnit I tell you what any
apocalypse scenario everyone always
comes up with like their survival guides
ever like if there was like a bomb
dropped or whatever I'm walking right at
it
and if any famine whatever I'm going
straight towards the death and I'm gonna
be like we had a good run
I'm grabbing my dog and my girlfriend
even if they're upset that I'm taking
them walking straight towards the light
yeah
you don't have to come with him but why
don't you let him do it I'm supposed to
protect by walking into horrible future
heroes of this whole scenario they're
the ones with to stick around it didn't
bring us all out of darkness I tell you
what once like you can't have food
delivered and Netflix's down writing the
light you put a bare minimum to go
you're gonna survive an apocalypse it
depends on what the apocalypse is like
I'll give you one zombie zombies that
come out this I watch a lot of fours on
fire whether it's a show where they make
knives not zombie show a knife making
sure first of all you need to know how
to make a weapon yeah but you kill him
with a gun to the head that's a very
that's of your assuming that all the
guns are still just laying around like I
don't have but it but I don't one thing
I can find some medals brannis area to
construct a good night versus country
his his kitchen in Jersey into a place
to smelt iron once you stab a couple
yeah I'm not going to get the knife back
I would have run out of steak knives
eventually you mean when you stab
someone you just let go I just
if I'm stamping design yes because you
don't want that
that first stab they get you with that
have to call into you you want to get in
cat back out I think it's crazy enough
to work happens I'm gonna kill you first
Chris I don't know if you can make the
cut if you won't get close to me cuz I'm
start my own clan of people who are just
for denial walk into imminent death
maybe it'll be more fun maybe I'm just
gonna be dead yeah alright we have to
keep going Jordan I think give a shout
out for us yeah the shout out is from
Tony Maldonado and he says Jordan
Mendoza make me believe in miracles
again I guess that's because I won the
pop-tart stacking challenge yesterday
guys check out that episode also Winkle
picker says Pizza Pizza
nice to meetcha and that's in reference
to me as well thanks for watching every
damn day this has been Jordan thanks for
watching every damn day this has been my
show oh we're all doing it then yeah
thanks for watching every damn day hey
you want to do it that's pretty good
[Music]